[Music]
most of our decisions whether we like it
or not most of our actions most of our
behavior most of experiences are
constantly being shaped at the
instinctual level I would argue that
about 90 to 95 percent of our decisions
even important decisions you might think
that you're being rational but keep in
mind that if you pick the rational brain
against the emotional brain in general
it is the emotional brain that is going
to be not in fact I have this quote out
there it says that the rational brain
does not be so it's not good at being
rational what it is good at is simply
rationalize what the emotional brain has
already decided to do and therefore it
behooves us to understand the workings
of the instinctual emotional brain
[Music]
neuromodulators like serotonin dopamine
cortisol etc have a significant impact
on who we are even for example who we
are in the morning compared to who we
are in the afternoon and that has a huge
significance in terms of the nature of
the decisions that we make in the
morning versus in the afternoon
[Music]
the answer to this question is that in
general it is far better off scheduling
your decision-making in the morning
because that's when the levels of the
natural levels of serotonin the natural
levels of dopamine serotonin is the
calming chemical dopamine is the
excitatory chemical serotonin levels are
going to be normal because when you wake
up in the morning senator levels aren't
going to be high as a result of which
you can start taking chances you're less
risk-averse but as what happens when as
the day begins to progress is that
there's a natural decline in the level
of serotonin as a result of which when
you're making decisions in the afternoon
you will tend to be more risk-averse and
therefore there'll be a tendency to
gravitate towards what we call the
status quo the classic status quo bias
and the status quo bias will manifest in
the form of an indecision and that's
what you'll see that very often
when you're making decisions important
decisions especially late in the
afternoon very often you end up
postponing those decisions because you
like to stick to the status quo
[Music]
sleep is extremely critical why because
there's one phase of sleep called deep
sleep or slow wave sleep and this is
where our natural levels of serotonin
dopamine etc come back to normal and
therefore if you don't get good quality
sleep what I mean by that is good
quality deep sleep or slow-wave sleep
you're likely to end up in waking up in
the morning with lower levels of
serotonin as a result of which you're
more likely to be in a type-1 mindset
fearful more likely to make decisions
out of fear more likely to be risk
averse etc previously people thought
that what Fitness does is it releases
endorphins in the brain because we all
feel good after a workout turns out it
is really not really not endorphins
turns out this is actually a precursor
to serotonin that is released when you
are going through a fitness workout and
therefore it is an it is an ass and it's
nature's way to keep our levels of
serotonin and dopamine high during the
day I always advise people to have a
high-protein breakfast good quality
protein it could be a whey protein it
could be egg protein egg white for
example why because as the day begins to
progress right you had a break for a
second 7 o'clock in the morning of the
day because to progress all these other
amino acids are getting absorbed past
the blood-brain barrier that one of the
last ones to be released and get
absorbed is tryptophan which is a
precursor to serotonin so which means
that if you had a high quality protein
breakfast in the morning by the time
you're hitting about 11:00 11:30 when
you're going to expect it down is when
you're going to get a serotonin boost
and therefore you're effective as
effective making decisions in the middle
of the day as you are in the morning
you
[Music]